Dave was in his late 20s, and it would not be accurate to say that he was living at home with his parents, but only because half the time he was staying at his sister's house. He was playing in a band, doing some writing, not making much money, and his parents were worried. And one day he was hanging out with his mom.
戴夫快三十岁了，如果说他住在父母家并不准确，因为他有一半时间都待在他姐姐家。他当时在一个乐队里，偶尔写点东西，挣不到什么钱，他的父母很担心他。有一天，他和妈妈待在一起。
We were coming home from going ice skating together, which right there you can see that out. To be fair, I like ice skating. I'm a quarter Canadian.
我们当时一起滑冰回家，从这一点你就能看出来。公平地说，我喜欢滑冰。我有四分之一的加拿大血统。
Wait, wait, wait. You can see what? What does that show that you went ice skating with your mom?
等等，等等。你能看出什么？你和你妈妈去滑冰说明了什么？
Well, most guys, after a certain age, wouldn't go regularly ice skating with their mom to like [? organ ?] sessions where you're skating arm in arm around. I mean this is the sort of stuff I would do with my mom, like pretty regularly.
嗯，大多数男人到了某个年纪，就不会经常陪妈妈去那种滑冰场，在那里你们还要手挽着手滑。我的意思是，这就是我跟我妈会做的事情，而且挺频繁的。
So they pull into the driveway. Dave's mom tells him there's going to be a benefit for this retirement home for nuns and priests. His mom's an old school Catholic who goes to mass every day. And she says it's going to be at a hotel in downtown Cleveland. They live in Cleveland. And Maureen McGovern, who sang the theme to The Poseidon Adventure back in the '70s was going to be the entertainment.
他们开车驶入车道。戴夫的妈妈告诉他，要为修女和神父的养老院举办一场慈善义演。他妈妈是个老派的天主教徒，每天都去做弥撒。她说活动将在克利夫兰市中心的一家酒店举行。他们住在克利夫兰。而且，曾在70年代演唱过《海神号遇险记》主题曲的莫琳·麦戈文将担任表演嘉宾。
And she's like, so I'm getting tickets. So let me know if you want to go. And I said, no, I don't want to go. And then, so she just said, OK, well just let me know then. She's like, because I have to get the tickets in the next couple of weeks. And I figured, I didn't give it any thought, but then it kept coming up over and over. Like, let me know, the benefit's coming up and I need to buy tickets. So are you going to go? And I said, no. And she said, all right, well I need to know by next week if you're going to go. And this just went on and on for a couple of weeks.
她说她要买票，让我考虑一下要不要去。我说不，我不想去。然后她说，好吧，到时候通知我。她说因为她得在未来几周内把票买好。我当时没怎么多想，但这件事被反复提起。比如，她说活动快到了，她需要买票，所以你到底去不去？我说不去。她说，好吧，那下周之前我得知道你是否会去。这种情况持续了好几周。
This was a big thing. My mom kept saying like, and there will be nuns and priests there. Like they're going to get some of the old nuns and priests from the retirement place out. You can walk up and touch them and stuff. I don't know why she made that a selling point.
这可是件大事。我妈一直说，到时候会有修女和神父在那儿。就好像他们要把养老院里的一些老修女和老神父接出来一样。你可以走过去摸摸他们之类的。我不知道她为什么要把这当作一个卖点。
Maybe that was a selling point for her. Maybe she likes nuns and priests.
也许这对她来说是个卖点。也许她喜欢修女和神父。
She does.
她确实喜欢。
And she knows some of the old ones from back in the day.
而且她认识一些当年在那里的老人家。
Oh yeah, she's super into nuns and priests.
哦，是的，她超级迷恋修女和神父。
And these weren't just the regular nuns and priests that she see's everyday on the ball field. These are some of the older players. You have the cards, you know, but you never see out of the stadium anymore.
而且这些并不是她平时在球场上见到的那种普通修女和神父。这些都是一些老面孔。就像你有球员卡一样，你知道，但在球场外你再也见不到他们了。
Yeah, exactly. It was like the fantasy league. Like Father Mackey from St. Anne's in 1952.
对，没错。就像梦幻联盟一样。就像1952年圣安妮教堂的麦基神父。
So there's a lot of that going on. And then, somewhere along the line, my mom brings up the fact that a priest that used to teach at my high school when I was there, Father Dennis, was recovering from two heart attacks. And so she's like, you know, I ran into Father Dennis up at church. And I was telling him about the benefit. And he was really into it. Yeah, I bet he would like to come to this benefit also. Why don't you bring him? And I was like, I'm not going. And she's like, well, I already told him you were going to call.
所以很多这类事情在发生。后来，我妈提到了我高中时的一位老师丹尼斯神父，他当时心脏病发作两次，正在康复中。我妈说，我在教堂碰到了丹尼斯神父，我跟他说了那个义演的事。他非常有兴趣。是啊，我打赌他也想来参加这个义演。你为什么不带他去呢？我说我不去。她说，可是我已经告诉他你会给他打电话了。
So Dave realizes he's trapped. Checkmate. He's going to have to at least call Father Dennis.
所以戴夫意识到他被困住了。将死。他至少得给丹尼斯神父打个电话。
And Father Dennis, was he just like another teacher at the school or was he somebody who you especially liked?
那么丹尼斯神父，他只是学校里的另一位老师，还是你特别喜欢的人？
I liked him. Yeah, I mean I knew him. He ran the choir. Yeah, I thought he was a great guy. He loaned me his guitar. He played guitar. So it wasn't like we had kept in touch or anything. You know, I had fond memories of him. But I hadn't seen him in years.
我喜欢他。是的，我的意思是，我认识他。他负责唱诗班。我觉得他是个好人。他还把吉他借给我用。他会弹吉他。我们并没有保持联系。你知道，我有关于他的美好回忆，但我已经很多年没见过他了。
So he gets Father Dennis on the phone and they agree that Dave is going to pick him up and they'll attend the event together.
于是他给丹尼斯神父打了电话，他们约定由戴夫去接他，然后一起参加活动。
Comes the big day, it goes exactly as you might imagine a lunchtime fundraiser for retired nuns and priests in a hotel in downtown Cleveland with Maureen McGovern singing usually goes. Now there were a couple of wild card moments to the day that I'll run through quickly for you.
大日子到了，活动正如你所想的那样，在克利夫兰市中心的一家酒店里举行了一场为退休修女和神父举办的午餐筹款会，还有莫琳·麦戈文的歌唱表演。在那一天，还有几个突发状况，我很快给你讲讲。
First, Dave runs into a friend at the event from grade school-- now gay-- whose Dave mom is convinced that they should set up with one of Dave's sisters, even though Dave tries to keep explaining to her that Guy is gay.
首先，戴夫在活动中遇到了一个小学同学——现在是个男同性恋——戴夫的妈妈确信应该把他介绍给戴夫的一个姐妹，尽管戴夫一直在向她解释那个人是同性恋。
And she thinks that I'm being mean, insulting him by calling him gay. I'm like, no, he's a gay man. That's fine. And just explain to me why it's not going to work out?
她觉得我说话刻薄，通过称他为同性恋来侮辱他。我说，不，他就是个男同性恋，这没关系。你能跟我解释一下为什么这事儿行不通吗？
Second, the luncheon buffet turns out to be mostly fried foods. None of which can be eaten by Father Dennis, who's still recovering from his two heart attacks and requested a special low fat meal. Though Dave's mom has come prepared for this.
第二，午餐自助餐大多是油炸食品。丹尼斯神父一样都吃不了，因为他心脏病发作两次后正在康复中，要求吃低脂餐。不过戴夫的妈妈早有准备。
She sort of like, looks around real quickly and then reaches under the table. And she snuck in a bag of bread and like sandwich meats thinking that we could just make some sandwiches for him at the table. And I'm just horrified.
她快速地看了看周围，然后伸手进桌子下面。她偷带了一袋面包和一些三明治肉片，以为我们可以在桌子上直接为他做三明治。我简直惊呆了。
Father Dennis tells her very politely, thanks, but no. He doesn't want a sandwich. And eventually the waiters do arrange for him to get some sort of meal. At their table are some very old people, Dave's parents, Dave, and Father Dennis.
丹尼斯神父很有礼貌地告诉她，谢谢，但不用了。他不想吃三明治。最终，服务员还是安排他吃上了一些合适的餐点。在他们的桌子旁，坐着一些非常老的老人、戴夫的父母、戴夫和丹尼斯神父。
There's no drinking, which Dave says might have really helped things. And after a while, Dave and Father Dennis have run out of small talk.
没有酒，戴夫说如果能喝点酒，情况可能会好转。过了一会儿，戴夫和丹尼斯神父已经无话可说了。
So it's getting quiet and we're sitting next to each other. At some point, Father Dennis turns to me and he's sort of like, you know, I don't know. Normally I understand why I'm somewhere. If I'm invited somewhere I know why. But I guess I don't know. I don't know why I'm here. I'm really confused. I don't feel any connection to this. And I was just like, what? What do you mean? I thought you wanted to be here. I thought that was the whole thing. That's why I'm here. I thought you wanted to be here.
现场变得安静，我们并排坐着。过了一会儿，丹尼斯神父转向我说，你知道，我不知道。通常我知道自己为什么会在某个地方。如果我受邀参加某个活动，我知道原因。但我猜我不知道。我不知道我为什么会在这儿。我真的很困惑。我感觉不到与这里有任何联系。我当时就说，什么？你什么意思？我以为你想来这里。我以为整件事就是这样。这就是我为什么在这儿的原因。我以为你想来。
And he says, no. Your mother told me that you wanted to be here and that you really wanted me to go. So I thought that I should do it for you and your mom. And we're just sitting there, like oh gosh. We've been just duped by what I thought was a really nice lady.
他说，不。你妈妈告诉我你想来，而且你非常希望我陪你去。所以我以为我应该为你和你妈这么做。我们当时就坐在那儿，心想，天哪，我们被那个我一直以为是很善良的女士给骗了。
My mother just tricked us into this.
我妈妈把我们给耍了。
Did you ask your mom afterwards about the whole thing?
事后你问你妈关于这件事了吗？
Yeah.
问了。
And did she explain what she was hoping was going to happen once she got you and Father Dennis together?
她有没有解释她把你和丹尼斯神父聚在一起是想达成什么目的？
No, she just kept saying like, oh, I just thought it would be a really nice time for you. For both of you. She was very invasive about it. And I confronted her saying, do you think like that I'm going to hang out with his priest and then I'm going to want to become a priest? And she's like, no.
没有，她只是一直说，哦，我只是觉得这对你们来说会是很棒的一段时光。对你们两个都是。她在这方面非常强人所难。我质问她说，你是不是觉得我会跟这个神父待在一起，然后就想去当神父了？她说，没有。
She wouldn't admit to that, and that's maybe--
她不承认，这也许——
But you think that's what it might be? Like in the back of her mind she's just like, maybe you're single, you're in your late 20s. Maybe you should be a priest?
但你觉得那可能是她的想法吗？就像在她潜意识里，她觉得，也许你单身，快三十岁了，也许你应该去当神父？
Maybe. Or at least have some sort of like priestly influence. I think there was like a bigger thing, but she'll never tell me.
也许吧。或者至少会受到某种神职人员的影响。我觉得背后还有更大的原因，但她永远不会告诉我。
Dave says this was par for the course. His mom often mystified him. And a certain amount of her parenting, of any parenting really, is putting your kids into situations you know are going to be good for them whether they like it or not. Or even, whether they understand it.
戴夫说这是常态。他妈妈经常让他感到困惑。某种程度上的育儿，或者说任何育儿方式，就是把你的孩子带入你认为对他们有益的环境中，不管他们喜不喜欢，甚至不管他们明不明白。
There's been a number of things over the years that I just could not wrap my head around why she was making me do it. And I really thought she was torturing me.
多年来，有很多事情我都无法理解她为什么要逼我做。我真的觉得她在折磨我。
Like what?
比如什么？
She made me take typing lessons that I could not fathom why. I was like 13-years-old, 14-years-old. It just seemed just random, like here's something that I'll hate. I'll just make him do it. And like, now, literally like it didn't even hit me until like the last few years when I realized that a huge part of everyday for me, I'm typing all the time. I remember seeing that one day and be like, oh my God. That's why she made me endure that horrible summer of typing lessons. Literally, 20 years later I figured it out why she did that to me.
她逼我上打字课，我完全无法理解原因。我当时大概13、14岁。这看起来很随机，就像这里有件我会讨厌的事，她就非要让我做。而现在，真的，直到最近几年我才意识到，我每天的大部分时间都在不停地打字。我记得有一天意识到这一点时，我说，噢，我的天哪。这就是她让我忍受那个可怕的暑假打字课的原因。真的，20年后我才弄明白她为什么要那么对我。
From WBEZ Chicago it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Today on our show, The Parent Trap, stories of parents doing their best to be good parents and do right by their kids by putting the kids into situation that they believe will be helpful. Our show in two acts today. Act one, Letter Day Saint. David Segal has the story of a mom doing something that you would expect and hope a mom would do, give her kid a little advice. Act two, The Opposite of Tarzan. We are very, very excited to have a brand new story from the amazing team that does the show Radiolab. This is a story about interspecies parenting. Stay with us.
今天我们的节目主题是“育儿陷阱”，讲述的是父母竭尽全力成为好家长，通过将孩子置于他们认为有帮助的处境中来对孩子负责的故事。我们今天有两幕。第一幕，“书信日圣徒”。大卫·西格尔带来了一位母亲的故事，她做了一件你期望且希望母亲会做的事，给她的孩子提供一点建议。第二幕，“泰山的对立面”。我们非常非常兴奋能从制作《放射实验室》的精彩团队那里带来一个全新的故事。这是一个关于跨物种育儿的故事。请继续收听。
Act 1, Letter Day Saint.
第一幕，书信日圣徒。
Sometimes a parent can do something kind of extraordinary, really above and beyond what most people do with the best of intentions, just looking out for their kid. And do I even need to say that they can have all kinds of unintended consequences. David Segal has this example.
有时，父母会做出一些相当非凡的事，真正超越了大多数人的所作所为，出发点都是为了孩子好。而且我甚至不需要说，他们可能还会导致各种意想不到的后果。大卫·西格尔就有这样一个例子。
In 1991, Elizabeth Gee was dying of cancer. And as she thought about the time she had left to live, she worried about her only child, Rebecca. Then 16 years old. And she discussed her worries with her husband.
1991年，伊丽莎白·吉死于癌症。当她想到自己余下的时光时，她担心她唯一的孩子，当时16岁的丽贝卡。她和丈夫讨论了她的担忧。
She just looked at me one night. I mean, she was hooked up with all of this stuff.
有一天晚上，她看着我。我是说，她身上连着各种管子。
This is Gordon Gee.
这是戈登·吉。
And she just looked at me. She said, you know, I really feel that I need to continue to be an influence on Rebecca's life and continue to be part of her life. She knew she was terminal. She knew that she only had about a month to live. And she made this discrimination that she was going to write letters to her daughter.
她就那么看着我。她说，你知道，我真的觉得我需要继续对丽贝卡的生活产生影响，并继续成为她生活的一部分。她知道自己身患绝症。她知道自己只剩下一个月的生命了。她做出了一个决定，那就是要给她女儿写信。
Specifically, birthday letters. The plan she told Gordon was this. She would write letters that he would send to Rebecca, one per year, every year, on December 4, Rebecca's birthday. The letters would be sealed and for Rebecca's eye's only. There were 13 of them. Each tailored for a specific birthday. Plus a letter for the day of Rebecca's wedding. Rebecca didn't know any of this until the first letter, which she read the day she turned 17.
具体来说，是生日信。她告诉戈登的计划是：她会写一些信，让他每年在12月4日，也就是丽贝卡的生日那天寄给丽贝卡。信会密封好，只供丽贝卡一个人看。总共写了13封。每一封都针对特定的生日。此外还有一封信是留给她婚礼那天看的。丽贝卡在收到第一封信之前对这一切一无所知，那是她17岁生日那天读到的。
To a daughter reeling from the loss of her mother, it was the ultimate birthday present.
对于一个沉浸在丧母之痛中的女儿来说，这是最好的生日礼物。
She said in one of my first letters that these were a way to connect to her. That all I had to do to connect to her was to open a letter. And then she would be there.
她在我的第一封信里说，这些信是与她建立联系的一种方式。我只需要打开一封信，就能与她产生连接。然后她就在那里了。
One of the early letters arrived on a birthday at college, when she was feeling particularly isolated.
其中一封早期的信是在她大学的一个生日送到的，当时她感到格外孤独。
And this letter said basically, you will never be alone. You will never be alone. You will always have me. And I just remember feeling this incredible feeling of peace. It almost felt like getting a letter from someone who was alive.
这封信基本上说，你永远不会孤单。你永远不会孤单。你永远会有我。我记得当时感到一种难以置信的平静。感觉就像收到了一位在世之人的信一样。
It happened the same way every year. Gordon, a college president for most of his professional life, now at Ohio State University, would overnight a sealed envelope, adding a brief card of his own. And every year, Rebecca went through a birthday letter ritual.
每年都以同样的方式发生。戈登，他职业生涯中大部分时间担任大学校长，现在在俄亥俄州立大学，会连夜寄出一个密封的信封，并附上他自己的一张简短贺卡。每年，丽贝卡都会经历这个生日信的仪式。
Usually sometime in the afternoon before dinner I'd sit down and open it and read Dad's note. Feel the page, look at her signature. Usually it'd be the first thing. And think, gosh, that's just so amazing that she's gone and I'm looking at her signature and it's saying I love you. And then I'd read through it.
通常在午饭后的某个下午，我会坐下来打开它，读爸爸写的便条。摸摸信纸，看看她的签名。通常那是最先触动我的。心想，天哪，她不在了，而我看着她的签名，它在说“我爱你”，这真是太神奇了。然后我会读下去。
Each letter was about 2,000 typed words on thick white paper signed by hand, "You're the sweetest girl in the world. Or just, "Love forever, Mommy."
每一封信大约有2000字，打印在厚厚的白纸上，亲笔签名为“你是世界上最贴心的女孩”，或者只是“永远爱你的妈妈”。
Elizabeth told Gordon that she wanted to describe the world as she saw it, and as Rebecca would see it as a young woman. And she does so in the letters with a mix of pep talks, moral instruction, autobiography, and parental affection. Often she focuses on what was happening to her on the age Rebecca would be when she opened each letter.
伊丽莎白告诉戈登，她想描述她眼中的世界，以及作为一名年轻女性，丽贝卡将会看到的世界。她在信中混合了鼓励、道德指导、自传和父母的关爱。她经常关注丽贝卡读到每一封信时可能会面临的情况。
So when Rebecca turned 21, Elizabeth described a dress she owned when she was 21. Quote, "You would not believe what I wore. A black fake fur suit with a pink top and the plastic ping pong earrings. Everyone thought it was fashionable, but I laugh when I think of it."
所以当丽贝卡21岁时，伊丽莎白描述了她21岁时穿的一件衣服。引用：“你简直无法想象我穿了什么。一件黑色人造皮草套装，配上一件粉色上衣和塑料乒乓球耳环。大家都觉得那很时髦，但现在想起我都会笑。”
A lot of the letters are advice on how to live. Quote, "Most children benefit from the simulation of daycare," she writes. Urging Rebecca not to give up her career when she has children. Quote, "You are not a uni-dimensional person. Under that balance, you will be frustrated."
很多信件都是关于如何生活的建议。引用：“大多数孩子受益于日托的模拟，”她写道。督促丽贝卡在有了孩子后不要放弃职业生涯。引用：“你不是一个单一维度的人。在这种平衡之下，你会感到沮丧。”
And her mother had high expectations. In one letter she asks her daughter, "Are you contemplating a dissertation? Interviewing with scientific laboratories or NASA? Traveling to excited places?" Rebecca pushed herself to meet those expectations.
而且她的母亲对她寄予厚望。在一封信中，她问她的女儿：“你在考虑写博士论文吗？在面试科学实验室或NASA吗？去令人兴奋的地方旅行了吗？”丽贝卡努力去实现这些期望。
In college when her friends were out drinking, she stayed in and studied. Other kids might have found this all a little too heavy, Rebecca found it inspiring.
在大学里，当朋友们出去喝酒时，她留下来学习。其他孩子可能会觉得这一切有点太沉重，丽贝卡却觉得这很激励人。
For example, when I decided I didn't have the confidence to go to medical school and I wasn't going to do it, the letter that year basically said, you need to find ethical expression in your work.
例如，当我决定自己没有信心去读医学院并且打算放弃时，那一年收到的那封信基本上说，你需要在你的工作中找到道德表现。
She ended up going to medical school.
她最终还是去了医学院。
There was just no way I could have become a banker in the setting of these letters. I mean not that bankers don't have ethical expression, but for most of college, I think I had this enormous sense of purpose that I had a responsibility to do something meaningful. Both to me and to other people.
在这种信件的背景下，我根本不可能成为一名银行家。我的意思是，并不是说银行家没有道德表现，但在大学的大部分时间里，我想我有一种巨大的目标感，觉得我有责任去做一些有意义的事情。对我自己和对别人都是如此。
As galvanizing as these letters could be, they could also be upsetting. The first person to fully appreciate how upsetting they were was her father. He was the one who dealt with the fall out. He saw that keeping his promise to his wife meant causing his daughter emotional distress. And on her birthday.
虽然这些信件可以起到激励作用，但也可能令人不安。第一个完全意识到这些信件有多令人不安的人是她的父亲。他是处理后果的人。他看到，信守对妻子的承诺意味着给女儿带来情感上的痛苦。而且还是在她的生日那天。
It was as if I could predict the sunrising. Rebecca would get the letters and then, I'd receive either that night or the next morning, a very tearful telephone call about how much she missed her mom. And I'd have these prolonged telephone calls.
就好像我可以预测太阳升起一样。丽贝卡会收到信，然后在那天晚上或第二天早上，我就会接到一个非常伤心的电话，诉说她有多想念妈妈。我就会接到这些漫长的电话。
What sort of things would you talk about?
你们会聊些什么？
Well, I mean, she'd just say she's sad. You know, very sad. I wish my mother had been able to live. And been able to be here for me when I needed her. And been able to go shopping with me and all the kinds of things that I think any young woman would love to have her mother do. And you can imagine, that was very difficult for me.
嗯，我的意思是，她只会说她很伤心。你知道，非常伤心。我希望我妈妈能活下来。希望在我需要她的时候她能在身边。希望她能陪我逛街，能做任何我认为任何年轻女性都希望母亲做的事情。你可以想象，这对我很困难。
Toward the end of her college years, the letters were difficult for Rebecca for another reason. One of her mother's regular theme, actually you could say it was the dominant theme, was religious faith. The Gee's are Mormons and to her mother, staying close to the church was essential.
在大学快结束时，这些信件对丽贝卡来说因为另一个原因而变得困难。她母亲经常谈论的主题，实际上你可以说是主导主题，是宗教信仰。吉家是摩门教徒，对她母亲来说，保持与教会的亲近至关重要。
The most important thing for her was that I be a Mormon woman in the way that she wanted me to be. Which was a woman that went to the temple. A woman who married a Mormon man. A woman who believed all of the Mormon theology.
对她来说最重要的事情就是，我成为她所期望的那种摩门教女性。也就是一个去圣殿的女性。一个嫁给摩门教男性的女性。一个相信所有摩门教神学的女性。
By the time Rebecca was a senior in college, she was moving away from the church. So she worried a lot about disappointing her mother, who in the letters was constantly imploring her to stay. Quote, "You must always have the goal of going to the temple. For there you receive great gifts. It is in the temple that we are joined in eternal bonds and powers that will unite us in the world's beyond."
当丽贝卡大学四年级时，她正逐渐疏远教会。所以她很担心会让母亲失望，因为母亲在信中不断恳求她留下来。引用：“你一定要始终以去圣殿为目标。在那里你会得到巨大的馈赠。正是在圣殿里，我们在永恒的纽带和力量中结合，这将把我们在来世团结在一起。”
In another letter she wrote, "You will make good life choices. I know you will. But no matter your choice, never lose sight of the temple for me, please."
在另一封信中她写道：“你会做出好的人生选择。我知道你会的。但无论你如何选择，请不要为了我而忽略圣殿，求你了。”
By age 21, after a few years of getting these letters and going through a process where I realized this right not going to be in my life, sometimes I would feel angry. And I remember at age 21 thinking, man, do I have to open up this one this year? This is tough. I don't want to do it. And my friend saying, well, why don't you wait? We'll go out to dinner. Maybe open it up tomorrow. And I felt guilty. And I remember feeling like if I didn't open it up I would really disappoint her. And yet, then I open it up and it's all about, I hope you marry a Mormon man and I hope you go to the temple. And if you don't go to the temple, you won't go to heaven. You're not going to see me. And I'm not doing it. And that's a pretty hard thing to hear on your birthday.
到了21岁，在收到这些信好几年并经历了意识到我的人生中不再有这个信仰的过程后，有时我会感到愤怒。我记得21岁时想，天哪，今年我非得打开这一封吗？这太难了。我不想这么做。我的朋友说，好吧，那你为什么不等等呢？我们出去吃晚饭。也许明天再打开。我感到内疚。我记得当时觉得如果我不打开它，我就会让她非常失望。然而，当我打开它时，里面全都是，我希望你嫁给一个摩门教男人，我希望你去圣殿。如果你不去圣殿，你就去不了天堂。你就见不到我了。我做不到这一点。在生日那天听到这些真的很痛苦。
Gordon was devout, but he could listen to Rebecca's reasons for leaving the church and came to accept them. Her mother couldn't do that. And in the three-way conversation that is part of any relationship of child, mother, and father, the voice of Rebecca's mother always spoke the loudest. It might seem strange that the deceased parent had the most sway, but her mother's opinion was fixed. There's no arguing with her. That haunted Rebecca. And while Gordon found himself reassuring his daughter, the comforts he offered were always trumped by Rebecca's memory of her mother.
戈登是一个虔诚的人，但他能倾听丽贝卡离开教会的理由，并开始接受它们。她的母亲做不到。在任何孩子、母亲和父亲的关系对话中，丽贝卡母亲的声音总是最大的。已故的父母对孩子有最大的影响力似乎很奇怪，但她母亲的观点是固定的。没法跟她争论。这困扰着丽贝卡。虽然戈登发现自己在安抚女儿，但他提供的安慰总是被丽贝卡对母亲的记忆所掩盖。
It's difficult to compete with a dead spouse or in this sense, a dead mother. Because I'm here and I have all of the frailties of who I am. And over time, obviously her mother became very iconic. In many ways, very perfect. And clearly, could do no wrong. And I mean I never did say this to her, although I've joked with her a couple times. You know, who am I, chopped liver?
与已故的配偶，或者在这种意义上，已故的母亲竞争是很困难的。因为我就在这里，我有我所有的软弱。随着时间的推移，她的母亲显然变得非常有偶像色彩。在很多方面，非常完美。显然，她不可能做错任何事。我的意思是，我从没对她说出口过，尽管我跟她开过几次玩笑。你知道，我是谁，不重要吗？
Because the letters were written exclusively for Rebecca, Gordon thought it was inappropriate to ask too many questions about them. For the same reason, Rebecca never volunteered to share them. Father and daughter were just following a set of instructions. As outdated and as trying as those instructions were.
因为这些信是专门为丽贝卡写的，戈登认为问太多问题是不合适的。同样的原因，丽贝卡也从没主动分享过。父女俩只是遵循了一套指令。尽管这些指令是如此过时且令人煎熬。
Over the years, as he dealt with his daughter's anguish, Gordon tossed out some hints the perhaps it was a bad idea for him to lob these annual grief bombs into her life.
多年来，当他应对女儿的痛苦时，戈登抛出了一些暗示，觉得他把这些年度悲伤炸弹投进她的生活可能是一个糟糕的主意。
I did on several occasions, I just said, you know, you have to remember that your mother was very ill. And that she loved you very much. But I'm not quite certain how healthy this is to have these letters and I said that to her directly. And I've said that to her on several occasions. And because it was very hard on me. It would really break my heart when I would hear her be so sad.
我有好几次直接对她说，你知道，你必须记住你母亲病得很重。她非常爱你。但我不太确定拥有这些信件对健康是否有益。这对我很艰难。当我听到她那么伤心时，真的会让我心碎。
But Rebecca never seemed to pick up on her father's hints, or his misgivings. As painful as the letters were, she felt as though she had no choice but to read them carefully. So Gordon sent them all, though he was conflicted about it enough that he actually delegated the FedExing part to his secretary.
但丽贝卡似乎从未领会她父亲的暗示或忧虑。尽管这些信件很痛苦，但她觉得她别无选择，只能仔细阅读它们。所以戈登把它们全寄了，尽管他内心很矛盾，以至于他实际上把联邦快递的任务委派给了秘书。
All of this letter related dread culminated with Rebecca's wedding, which happened in 2006 in an Episcopal church. But Rebecca and Gordon suspected the letter Elizabeth wrote for Rebecca's wedding would contain her longest course yet on the importance of marrying in a Mormon temple. Which is why both father and daughter told me they were secretly relieved when the letter, which Gordon's secretary says she sent, vanished in the FedEx system.
所有这些与信件相关的恐惧在丽贝卡的婚礼上达到了顶峰，婚礼发生在2006年的一座圣公会教堂。但丽贝卡和戈登怀疑伊丽莎白为婚礼写的信会包含她最长的一堂关于在摩门教圣殿结婚重要性的课程。这就是为什么父女俩都告诉我，当那封由戈登秘书说她寄出的信在联邦快递系统中消失时，他们暗暗松了一口气。
I remember thinking, if there is one for my wedding, I definitely don't want to open it on my wedding day. Because I really want my wedding day to be happy. And I don't want to sit, I don't want to cry. That day in particular, didn't want the letter to be a part of it.
我记得当时想，如果婚礼有一封信，我绝对不想在婚礼当天打开。因为我真的希望我的婚礼当天是快乐的。我不想坐着，不想哭。那天尤其如此，我不希望这封信成为婚礼的一部分。
Because all the birthday letters had been sent, the wedding letter would have been the final letter in the series.
因为所有的生日信都已经寄出，这封婚礼信将是系列中的最后一封。
Was there part of you when the letters ran out that felt relief?
当信件寄完时，你内心有没有一种如释重负的感觉？
Yeah, I think so. I think that without a doubt, it was an opportunity to move on. On the other level, this was the last kind of visible written, tangible connection that she had with her mother.
有，我想是的。毫无疑问，这是一个继续前进的机会。在另一个层面上，这是她与母亲之间最后一种可见、书面、有形的联系。
It's almost like another death?
这几乎就像是又一次死亡？
Right. And I think it was to her in many ways.
对。而且我认为在很多方面对她来说确实如此。
But it was also a new beginning. For the first time, Rebecca began living a life that wasn't shadowed by a looming reminder of her mother's unmet hopes. Rebecca had become a physician. And she married a doctor named Allan Moore, whom she had met in residency. It was a very happy marriage and it ended tragically, a mere 18 months after it started when the couple was hit by an SUV while riding a Vespa.
但这也是一个新的开始。丽贝卡第一次开始过上不再被母亲未实现的愿望的阴影所笼罩的生活。丽贝卡成为了一名医生。她嫁给了一位名叫艾伦·摩尔的医生，他们是在住院实习期间认识的。这是一段非常幸福的婚姻，但在开始仅18个月后就悲剧性地结束了，当时夫妇俩在骑Vespa摩托车时被一辆SUV撞倒。
Rebecca was severely injured and Allan was killed. For the second time in her life, Rebecca was forced to cope with a devastating loss. But this time was different. She spent her months of physical rehab contemplating and writing about her memories of Allan.
丽贝卡受了重伤，艾伦去世了。丽贝卡一生中第二次被迫面对毁灭性的损失。但这次不同了。她在身体康复的几个月里沉思并写下了关于艾伦的记忆。
And I remember thinking to myself, this is how it should be when you grieve for someone. You should remember the beautiful times, the things you shared. You should celebrate that person, but you shouldn't be dragged back into the grave with them every year. Why did she do this to me?
我记得当时想，当你为某人哀悼时，这就是应该的方式。你应该记住美好的时光，你们分享的一切。你应该庆祝那个人，但不应该每年都被拖回坟墓里。她为什么要对我这样做？
Rebecca says a year and a half after her husband's death, she feels like she's farther along in her grieving for him than she was 10 years after her mother died.
丽贝卡说，在丈夫去世一年半后，她觉得自己在为他哀悼的过程中比她母亲去世10年后走得更远。
I mourned my husband's loss, Allan's loss. I love him, but I'm moving on with my life as he would want me to. I think to have letters from him for my birthdays or a yearly, would make it harder for me to move on.
我哀悼我丈夫的失去，艾伦的失去。我爱他，但我像他所希望的那样，正在继续我的生活。我认为如果每年生日都收到他的信，会让我更难继续前进。
At the same time, the letters her mother sent were so essential in forming the person that Rebecca became, it's hard for her to imagine growing up without them.
与此同时，她母亲寄来的信对塑造现在的丽贝卡至关重要，她很难想象没有它们会怎样长大。
In the end, would I have wanted a life without these? I can't say that because they made me feel incredibly loved. They made me know how much she valued her time on this earth with me. I got to hear that. I got to hear that after she died.
最后，我是否希望拥有没有这些信的生活？我不能那么说，因为它们让我感到被深深地爱着。它们让我知道她在地球上与我共度的时光对她来说有多么珍贵。我听到了这些。我在她去世后听到了这些。
Recently, Rebecca has started to grasp the hardships the letters imposed on her dad. And she thinks it would've been better if she had shared the letters with her father in real time, even if that went against her mother's wishes. This surely wasn't Elizabeth's intention, but when she wrote those letter, she left behind the bricks for a wall that kept her husband and her daughter apart, at least when the subject came to Elizabeth. Along with instructions that made discussing that wall very difficult. It was a plan that neither Rebecca nor Gordon ever consented to. And now, very gingerly, the wall is being dismantled.
最近，丽贝卡开始理解这些信件给她父亲带来的困难。她认为，如果她能实时与父亲分享这些信件会更好，即使这违背了母亲的意愿。这当然不是伊丽莎白的初衷，但当她写那些信时，她留下了一堵墙的砖块，让丈夫和女儿之间产生了隔阂，至少在涉及伊丽莎白的问题上是这样。而且这些指令让讨论那堵墙变得非常困难。这是一个丽贝卡和戈登从未同意过的计划。现在，非常小心地，那堵墙正在被拆除。
A months ago Rebecca sent her Dad a copy of one of the letters from her 24th birthday. Much of which is about Gordon's strengths as a dad. She has yet to share any of the others. And during our interview, Gordon joked that he was a little jealous that I got to read the letters before he did.
几个月前，丽贝卡把她24岁生日时收到的一封信复印件寄给了父亲。信的大部分内容是关于戈登作为父亲的优点。她还没分享过其他的信。在我们的采访中，戈登开玩笑说，他有点嫉妒我竟然比他先读到了这些信。
But a dying wish has a momentum all its own. And though the letters are now locked in a safe in Gordon's home, he still hasn't looked at them. And Rebecca still hasn't asked him to.
但遗愿有其自身的力量。虽然信件现在锁在戈登家里的保险箱里，但他还是没看它们。丽贝卡也还没要求他看。
David Segal is a reporter for the New York Times .
大卫·西格尔是《纽约时报》的记者。
[MUSIC- "PAGES OF MY LETTERS" BY KERI NOBLE]
[音乐- 克里·诺布尔的《我信件的页面》]
Coming up, a set of parents like any others trying to impress their values on their child. Though in this case it's tricky because the child is not in their same species. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，一对像其他任何父母一样试图把自己的价值观灌输给孩子的父母。不过在这种情况下，这很棘手，因为孩子不是同一个物种。稍后从芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Each week on our program of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Parent Trap, we have stories of parents doing their best to be conscientious loving parents, accidentally setting traps for their kids or themselves along the way. We've arrived at act 2 of our show. Act 2, The Opposite of Tarzan.
我们的节目每周都会选择一个主题，带给你关于这个主题的不同故事。今天的节目，“育儿陷阱”，讲述的是尽职尽责、充满爱心的父母在无意中为孩子或自己设下陷阱的故事。我们进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“泰山的对立面”。
The parents in this next story do a lot of things that  are really just amazing. They actually reach outside their own species into a different species, adopt a baby, raise it, love it, without really thinking through the consequences. Which turn out to be big. Here are the hosts of Radiolab, Jad Abumrad and Robert Krulwich, and the story this baby, Lucy.
接下来这个故事里的父母做了一些真正令人惊叹的事情。他们实际上超出了自己的物种，跨越到另一个物种，领养了一个婴儿，抚养它，爱它，却没有真正思考过后果。结果证明后果很大。这是《放射实验室》的主持人贾德·阿布姆拉德和罗伯特·克鲁维奇，以及这个婴儿露西的故事。
So let's just start at the beginning. Who is Lucy?
那么让我们从头开始吧。露西是谁？
Lucy is a chimpanzee that actually, this was found out later, born to a circus entertainer. Born in their camp.
露西是一只黑猩猩，实际上，这是后来才发现的，她出生于一个马戏团艺人。出生在他们的营地里。
What country are we in?
我们在哪个国家？
In the US. They traveled up and down the East Coast, the [UNINTELLIGIBLE] Chimp Arc Show, something like that. They were very popular.
在美国。他们在东海岸巡回演出，什么什么黑猩猩秀，之类的。他们非常受欢迎。
We heard about Lucy from Charles Siebert, he's a reporter. And he tells the tale of a chimpanzee. She was a chimpanzee born-- do you know Jad?
我们是从查尔斯·西伯特那里听说露西的，他是一名记者。他讲述了一个黑猩猩的故事。她是一只黑猩猩出生——你知道吗，贾德？
1964.
1964年。
This is an early version of a chimp raised entirely in a human environment.
这是早期完全在人类环境中抚养的黑猩猩之一。
One of the earliest. But it's not the kind of story that you may have heard before, where the chimp grows up with humans and then actually ends up mauling the humans.
最早之一。但这并不是你以前可能听过的那种故事，那种黑猩猩和人类一起长大，最后却伤害了人类的故事。
This is much more complex than that.
这要复杂得多。
And Charles, himself, first bumped into the tale in this really old, obscure memoir.
查尔斯本人也是在一本非常古老、鲜为人知的回忆录中偶然发现了这个故事。
Long out of print.
早就绝版了。
Yeah, what's the name of the book?
是的，那本书的名字是什么？
Do you actually have it with you?
你真的带在身边吗？
Hold on. It's called Lucy- Growing Up Human : A Chimpanzee Daughter in a Psychotherapist's Family by Maurice K. Temerlin.
等一下。书名叫《露西——成长为人：心理治疗师家庭中的黑猩猩女儿》，作者是莫里斯·K·特默林。
Maurice K. Temerlin, he is the psychotherapist.
莫里斯·K·特默林，他就是那位心理治疗师。
He's a psychotherapist.
他是位心理治疗师。
And he's also the dad in this story. And his wife, Jane, who's a social worker, she's the mom. Now the thing to know was that, especially for Maurice Temerlin, this was more than just adopting a baby champ. This was an experiment. He wanted to know, given the right upbringing, how human could Lucy he become?
他也是这个故事里的爸爸。他的妻子简是一位社会工作者，她是妈妈。需要知道的是，特别是对莫里斯·特默林来说，这不仅仅是领养了一只黑猩猩宝宝。这是一项实验。他想知道，在适当的教养下，露西能变得多像人类？
What he says early on in this book, "Would she learn to love us and perhaps--
他在书的开头说，“她会学会爱我们，也许——
--have other human emotions as well? Would she be well-behaved, rebellious.
——还会产生其他人类情感吗？她会表现良好、叛逆吗？
Intelligent or stupid?
聪明还是愚蠢？
What about sex?
性生活呢？
Maurice Temerlin actually died in 1989, but these are his words read by radio host, David Garland.
莫里斯·特默林实际上于1989年去世，但这些话是由电台主持人戴维·加兰朗读的。
Would she mother her offspring? Could she learn to talk? How intelligent might she be?
她会像母亲一样对待她的后代吗？她能学会说话吗？她会有多聪明？
And so how did they her?
那么他们是怎么得到她的？
He says that he and his wife, Jane, made all the arrangements. Went and got the chimp--
他说他和妻子简做好了所有安排。去把这只黑猩猩带回来——
--from the day the infant was born.
——从婴儿出生的那天起。
The mother was anesthetized.
母亲被麻醉了。
In the early morning of her second day, Jane fed the mother a Coca-Cola, which had been spiked with phencyclidine, a drug which puts chimpanzees into a deep, pleasant sleep.
在她出生第二天的清晨，简给母亲喂了一杯可口可乐，里面混入了苯环己哌啶，这是一种能让黑猩猩进入深度、舒适睡眠的药物。
And the baby was taken away.
婴儿被带走了。
Jane named her Lucy and brought her home on a commercial airline, carried in a bassinet, her face covered with a lacy blanket. We were blissfully unaware of the complexities we were creating on the day Lucy came home.
简给她取名露西，通过商业航空公司把她带回家，装在一个摇篮里，脸上盖着一条蕾丝毯子。当露西回家的那天，我们全然不知道我们正在制造复杂的事情。
So the baby was a day or two old?
所以婴儿才一两天大？
Just two days old.
只有两天大。
So it wasn't weened?
所以还没断奶？
No, and that was part of the experiment.
不，这也是实验的一部分。
They bottle feed her.
他们用奶瓶喂她。
Yeah.
是的。
She quickly learned to hold her own bottle. At two months, her eyes would focus. At three months, she was trying to climb out of her crib to go to people. And at six months, she was pretty mobile on all four limbs.
她很快学会了自己拿着奶瓶。两个月大时，她的眼睛能聚焦了。三个月大时，她试图爬出婴儿床去找人。六个月大时，她的四肢移动已经非常灵活了。
The memoir goes on. By the time she was about a year old--
回忆录继续写道。当她大约一岁大时——
She was eating at the table with us.
她和我们一起在餐桌上吃饭。
Forks, spoons, knives.
叉子、勺子、刀子。
She would see us using silverware and immediately dos o herself.
她看到我们使用银器，立刻也会自己使用。
She began to dress herself in skirts.
她开始穿裙子。
Shw would often grab my hand, pull me to my feet and beg me to chase her. Always looking back to see that Daddy was not too far behind.
她经常抓住我的手，拉我站起来，求我追她。总是回头看看爸爸是不是离得不远。
You know, he really went at this with this sort of full bore earnestness. You know, when he calls her his darling daughter--
你知道，他确实以一种非常认真、全神贯注的态度对待这件事。你知道，当他称她为宝贝女儿时——
I took great pride in my daughter's achievements.
我为女儿取得的成就感到非常自豪。
He does feel like a real parent to Lucy.
他确实觉得自己是露西真正的父母。
She was so responsive to being looked at, held, and stroked.
她对被注视、被拥抱和被抚摸非常敏感。
But he's also, make no mistake, treating this as a very intense cutting edge experiment.
但请不要搞错，他也把这当作一个非常激烈、前沿的实验来对待。
The next phase of the experiment, which occupies a good deal of the book, involve one of those talents that we thought used to only be limited to us: language.
实验的下一阶段，占据了书的大部分内容，涉及到我们以前认为只有我们才有的那种天赋：语言。
OK.
好的。
Can you introduce yourself, please?
你能自我介绍一下吗？
OK, my name is Roger Fouts. I'm a professor of psychology and I've worked with chimpanzees since 1967.
好的，我叫罗杰·福茨。我是一名心理学教授，从1967年开始研究黑猩猩。
Roger Fouts was called in by Maurice Temerlin to address one of the crucial questions of the experiment.
罗杰·福茨被莫里斯·特默林请来解决实验中一个关键问题。
Could she learn to talk?
她能学会说话吗？
Right.
对。
And at the time, he was the guy. He had just been part of a team that had proven for the first time the chimps could use sign language to communicate. So his job with Lucy was to teach her how to sign.
当时，他就是专家。他刚参与了一个团队，首次证明了黑猩猩可以使用手语进行交流。所以他与露西的工作就是教她如何打手语。
And I think I came into her life when she was-- as I remember, it was 1970. I think it was four or five. She was four or five years old.
我想我进入她生活的时候，她——我记得是1970年。我想她当时四五岁。她四五岁大。
Roger taught her signs for airplane, baby doll, ball, banana, barrette, berry, bird.
罗杰教她“飞机”、“洋娃娃”、“球”、“香蕉”、“发夹”、“浆果”、“鸟”的手语。
Yeah, so I was sort of like--
是的，所以我就像是——
Blanket.
毯子。
--the tutor friend, babysitter that would come over for a few hours each day and spend some time just playing with Lucy. I would work on signs.
——那个每天过来陪她玩几个小时的导师、朋友、保姆。我会教她手语。
Cat.
猫。
We'd read books together, or we'd go for walks. I would chat with her basically.
我们会一起读书，或者去散步。我基本上会和她聊天。
Cry. Dirty.
哭。脏。
And he says that Lucy--
他说露西——
Enough.
够了。
Just sort of--
简直就是——
Picked it up.
学会了。
Picked it all up.
全部学会了。
It was like a game.
这就像个游戏。
She learned some 250 signs. And the big question is, OK, so is it me or mimicry, or are they able to spontaneously create words and put some together in a new original way? And there's been a lot of anecdotal evidence that in fact, Lucy did spontaneously create words.
她学会了大约250个手语词汇。最大的问题是，好的，那是模仿，还是她们能够自发地创造词汇并以一种全新的原始方式将它们组合在一起？有很多轶事证据表明，实际上，露西确实自发地创造了词汇。
In a later session, when shown a piece of watermelon, Lucy tasted it and she called it candy drink. When shown an onion before Roger good teach her the ASL sign for onion, Lucy volunteered--
在后来的一个环节中，当展示一片西瓜时，露西尝了尝，把它称为“糖果饮料”。在罗杰教她美式手语中“洋葱”的打法之前，当被展示一个洋葱时，露西主动给出了——
Cry hurt food.
“哭痛食物”。
Wow.
哇。
She would also lie to me.
她还会对我撒谎。
Really?
真的吗？
Yes.
是的。
And lying we should also say is another one of those things that people used to think only we do.
我们应该说，撒谎也是人们过去认为只有我们人类才会做的事情之一。
During one of my sessions I came in and she had a potty accident. She had been potty trained, but sometimes she didn't always make it. And I was upset because I was now faced with having to clean it up. And so I said, who's is that? And she said, Sue.
在我的一次教学中，我进去的时候她弄脏了厕所。她已经接受过如厕训练，但有时她并不总是能做到。我感到很沮丧，因为现在我得清理它。所以我说，那是谁弄的？她说，苏。
Who's Sue?
苏是谁？
Sue was one of my students that would come in and spend time with Lucy too. I said, no, Sue's not here.
苏是我的学生之一，也会过来陪露西玩。我说，不，苏不在。
She blamed it on Sue.
她把责任推给了苏。
Finally she fessed up and yeah, said Lucy. And sorry.
最后她承认了，说“露西。对不起。”
Sue?
苏？
Yes
是的。
This is Sue.
这是苏。
Sue Savage [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
苏·萨维奇。
The grad student of yours who says she didn't actually see that like take place.
你的研究生，她说她实际上并没有亲眼目睹那一幕。
Yes, well I wasn't there.
是的，嗯，我当时不在场。
But she told us that when she met Lucy, she was blown away by the incongruity of it all. Like for instance, every time she would walk in the house, Lucy would just--
但她告诉我们，当她见到露西时，她对这一切的不协调感到震惊。例如，每次她走进房子，露西就会——
Walk casually into the kitchen and search through the cupboard for the kind a tea she wanted that day, and put some water in a kettle and put it on the stove and make us tea. But it was the casualness with which she did it, the kind of air about it that yes, I'm making tea, and I would like you to have some too. Because tea is what we do. When we meet new people, we have tea.
随意走进厨房，在橱柜里搜索她那天想要喝的茶，往水壶里加水，放在炉子上，给我们煮茶。但这做事的随意性，那种氛围，是的，我在煮茶，我也想让你喝点。因为茶是我们所做的事情。当我们见到新人时，我们会喝茶。
Wow.
哇。
Lucy her developed an awareness of our emotions. If Jane is distressed--
露西发展出了对我们情绪的感知。如果简感到痛苦——
Temerlin's wife.
特默林的妻子。
--Lucy notices it immediately and attempts to comfort her by putting her arm about her, grooming her or kissing her.
——露西会立即察觉到，并试图通过搂着她、为她梳理毛发或亲吻她来安慰她。
If Jane is sick, Lucy would exhibit tender protectiveness toward her. Bringing her food, sharing her own food.
如果简生病了，露西会表现出温柔的保护欲。给她带食物，分享她自己的食物。
As we get to this next part, this is sort of the midpoint of the memoir. It's useful to sort of remember a basic fact of biology. Speciation happens when you've got one group of creatures that gets divided into two, and then these two groups evolve away from one another. And eventually they get so far away from each other that they can't have babies.
当我们进入下一部分时，这算是回忆录的中间点。记住一个基本的生物学事实是有用的。物种形成发生在当你有一群生物分裂成两组，然后这两组逐渐进化远离彼此。最终它们相距太远，无法繁衍后代。
And nature makes sure that they can't have babies by making one species basically undesirable to the other. You look across, you're a baboon. You look across at a chimp and you go, eh.
大自然通过使一个物种基本上对另一个物种没有吸引力来确保它们无法繁衍。你环顾四周，你是一只狒狒。你看看黑猩猩，你会说，额。
Yeah, you're only sexually attracted to your own kind. That is essentially what a species is.
是的，你只会对自己这种生物产生性吸引。这本质上就是一个物种。
This isn't something you're supposed to be able to learn or unlearn.
这不是你应该能够学会或忘记的东西。
This is just the way it is.
这就是事实。
Yeah, which brings us to some troubling passages in the book. Beginning really on page 105.
是的，这把我们引向了书中一些令人不安的段落。实际上是从第105页开始的。
Can you read it?
你能读一下吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And we should warn that this next minute and a half contains s sexual reference.
我们应该警告，接下来的一分半钟包含性相关内容。
One afternoon around 5 o'clock, Jane and I were sitting in the living room when we observed this sequence of behavior.
一天下午5点左右，简和我坐在客厅里，观察到了这一连串的行为。
Lucy left the living room and went to the kitchen, opened a cabinet, and took from it a glass. Opened a different cabinet and brought out a--
露西离开客厅去了厨房，打开一个柜子，从中拿出一个玻璃杯。打开另一个柜子，拿出了一个——
Bottle of gin.
一瓶杜松子酒。
Gin?
杜松子酒？
Yeah. She loved gin and tonics.
是的。她喜欢杜松子酒加奎宁水。
That's actually not the important part. It's what happens next.
那实际上不是重点。重点是接下来发生的事。
She takes her gin and goes back to the living room, sits on the couch, and there's really no other way to say this. She starts to masturbate. But even that's not the important part. It's actually the very next moment. That a boundary that took proximity six million years to establish dissolves. Mr. Temerlin sees Lucy doing this and he thinks, hmm, this? This is a perfect experimental moment. So he runs off to the mall.
她带着杜松子酒回到客厅，坐在沙发上，确实没有别的说法。她开始自慰。但即使那也不是重点。重点实际上是接下来的那一刻。一个历经六百万年才建立的边界消失了。特默林先生看到露西这样做，心想，嗯，这？这是一个完美的实验时刻。所以他跑去商场。
Buys a copy of Plagirl magazine and brings it back to her.
买了一本《花花公子》之类的杂志带回来给她看。
Because it's full of naked guys?
因为里面满是裸体男人？
Yep. And Lucy would masturbate to these centerfolds.
没错。露西会对着这些插页自慰。
I was not a part of that. I was never there when Lucy looked at the porno.
我没参与那件事。露西看色情刊物时我从不在场。
But Sue says that she was there for what happened next.
但苏说她当时在场，见证了接下来发生的事情。
Yes. I was there when she was introduced to her first adult male chimpanzee.
是的。当她被介绍给她的第一只成年雄性黑猩猩时，我在场。
Had Lucy ever seen another chimpanzee before?
露西以前见过其他黑猩猩吗？
Never seen another chimpanzee from the moment of birth.
从出生那一刻起就从未见过其他黑猩猩。
Wow.
哇。
She says they brought this male chimp in
她说他们把这只雄性黑猩猩带进来——
To see if Lucy was attracted to chimpanzee males.
看看露西是否对雄性黑猩猩感兴趣。
And was she?
她感兴趣吗？
Well, the male chimpanzee would sit there with his hand held out toward her and she was very frightened. And she tried to move away.
嗯，那只雄性黑猩猩伸着手坐在那里，她非常害怕。她试图躲开。
It was then, says sue, that she realized that in every way that mattered, Lucy was no longer a chimp. She was stranded.
就在那时，苏说，她意识到在每一个重要的方面，露西都不再是一只黑猩猩了。她被困住了。
Right in between this great divide that I knew was there between humans and non-humans. And I did not know how to negotiate this. There is no category in our language, except a mythical one for something that's not human and not animal.
就在我知道人类与非人类之间存在的那条巨大鸿沟之间。我不知道该如何处理这个问题。我们的语言中除了神话类别，没有其他类别来形容这种既不是人也不是动物的东西。
Insofar as this was an experiment, Maurice Temerlin wrote about it as a kind of triumph. Human nurture conquers chimpanzee nature. But slowly, over time, nature reasserted itself. As Lucy grew, became five, and then seven, and then nine--
就这是一项实验而言，莫里斯·特默林将其写成了一种胜利。人类的抚养征服了黑猩猩的天性。但随着时间的推移，天性缓慢地重新占据了上风。随着露西成长，五岁，然后七岁，然后九岁——
10 going on 11--
十岁快十一岁了——
She became strong says Charles. Really strong.
她变得强壮，查尔斯说。非常强壮。
They had by this time, rigged up an entire portion of the house for this very strong willful animal. Behind bars, padded rooms so you can bounce--
到那时，他们已经为这只非常强壮、固执的动物改装了整间房子。设了栅栏，铺了软垫房间，这样她可以跳——
Behind bars? They built a cage inside the house?
栅栏？他们在房子里建了个笼子？
In their house.
在他们自己的家里。
To which defeats the entire purpose of the whole thing.
这违背了整件事的初衷。
That's right.
没错。
Was she destroying things?
她在破坏东西吗？
Oh God, she was tearing the house to sheds.
天哪，她把房子拆了个底朝天。
Lucy was into everything. She could take a normal living room and turn it into pure chaos in less than five minutes.
露西什么都弄。她能在五分钟内把一个正常的客厅变成彻底的混乱。
Now that she's grown and is five to seven times stronger than I am, she could tear us apart, literally.
现在她长大了，力气是我五到七倍，她真的能把我们撕成碎片。
It was more and more challenging and time-consuming and upsetting to the extent that he and his wife finally said, all right, we can't do this anymore. This is too much.
这件事变得越来越具有挑战性、耗时且令人心烦，以至于他和妻子最后说，好吧，我们不能再这样做了。这太过分了。
Experiment over.
实验结束。
The memoir ends with a big fat question, what will happen to Lucy? On the final page, Maurice Temerlin says, well, we know we can't keep her, but we don't know what to do. The end.
回忆录以一个巨大的问号结束，露西会怎么样？在最后一页，莫里斯·特默林说，嗯，我们知道我们不能留住她，但我们不知道该怎么办。完。
I was raised in the romantic tradition and I like books to have happy endings. If they don't have happy endings, they should have tragic endings. I hate books which have no ending, like this one.
我是在浪漫传统中长大的，我喜欢有圆满结局的书。如果它们没有圆满的结局，它们应该有悲剧的结局。我讨厌像这本一样没有结局的书。
Hi.
嗨。
Hi, is this Janice?
嗨，是珍妮丝吗？
Yes it is.
是的，是我。
This is Janice Carter. Not only does she know the ending of the story, she's actually the key player in it.
这是珍妮丝·卡特。她不仅知道故事的结局，她实际上还是其中的关键人物。
Yeah, I hope we have a decent conversation because the lines here are really terrible.
是的，我希望我们的谈话能顺利，因为这里的信号真的很差。
It took us a really long time to find Janice Cater. She lives in a remote part of Gambia in Western Africa. And that'll become relevant in a second.
我们花了很长时间才找到珍妮丝·卡特。她住在西非冈比亚的一个偏远地区。这很快就会变得相关。
How did you meet Lucy?
你是怎么认识露西的？
I met her through one of my part time jobs that I had to put myself through grad school, was to clean Lucy's cage. That's how I met her. I cleaned up after her.
我通过研究生期间的一份兼职工作认识了她，工作是清理露西的笼子。这就是我认识她的方式。我负责清理她的排泄物。
In fact, Janice says, she was one of the few people who could actually handle Lucy when she was out of her cage.
事实上，珍妮丝说，她是少数几个能在露西出笼时真正控制住她的人之一。
Besides the Temerlins because she had been quite difficult with previous caretakers.
除了特默林夫妇，因为她之前对看护人员相当难对付。
Was that because you were stronger than the predecessor caretakers or you were cleverer?
那是由于你比之前的看护人更强壮，还是因为你更聪明？
Well, I think it was probably more timing. I think that the time that I entered Lucy's, she was looking something outside of that sphere of mom and dad. And I was a friend.
嗯，我觉得这可能更多是时机问题。我觉得当我进入露西的生活时，她正在寻找除了妈妈和爸爸那个圈子之外的东西。而我是一个朋友。
In any case, Janice ended up being in Lucy's life at the exact moment when the Temerlin's finally decided what they were going to do with Lucy.
无论如何，珍妮丝在露西的生活中出现的时刻，正是特默林夫妇最终决定如何处置露西的时候。
They visited a number of--
他们参观了许多——
It's 1977. They had just spent a year traveling around the world, looking at different options: zoos, research labs, chimp retirement homes, which were these facilities that were springing up to house chimps like Lucy, who'd been raised by humans or in the circus. But every place they visited she says, was just too depressing for them. Too cage-like, for this being that they essentially considered their daughter. And so the decision they came to was that the best way to honor Lucy, the best way to really make her happy was to simply let her go in the wild. And they asked Janice to help them do it.
那是1977年。他们刚花了一年时间环游世界，考察了不同的选择：动物园、研究实验室、黑猩猩养老院，这些是为了安置像露西这样由人类抚养长大或来自马戏团的黑猩猩而涌现的设施。但她说的每一个地方，对他们来说都太令人沮丧了。太像牢笼了，对这个他们本质上视为女儿的生命来说。所以他们得出的结论是，尊重露西的最好方式，真正让她快乐的最好方式就是简单地让她回归自然。他们请求珍妮丝帮助他们做到这一点。
Did you have any idea or any experience of what you were getting yourself into?
你有没有任何想法或经验，知道自己卷入了什么吗？
Zero. I didn't have a clue.
零。我根本不知道。
So after a 22 hour flight, Janice, the Temerlins, and Lucy arrive in Dakar, Senegal.
所以经过22小时的飞行，珍妮丝、特默林夫妇和露西抵达了塞内加尔的达喀尔。
I remember arriving really early in the morning and how hot it was even early in the morning.
我记得清晨到达时，即使是清晨也那么热。
Compared to Oklahoma, this was just different.
与俄克拉荷马州相比，这只是不同。
Lots of insects and mosquitoes and high, high, high humidity. It was the rainy season.
有很多昆虫和蚊子，湿度非常非常高。那是雨季。
After they landed, she says they piled into a car.
降落后，她说他们挤进了一辆车。
And crossed the Gambia River.
穿过了冈比亚河。
And then made their way to a nature reserve.
然后去了自然保护区。
A nature reserve.
自然保护区。
Which was basically just a bunch of big cages.
那里基本上只是一堆大笼子。
Really large enclosures there--
里面有非常大的围栏——
Sitting right outside in the jungle. So they get there, coax Lucy into one of these cases, say their goodbyes for the night, and they leave her to spend her very first night alone outdoors.
坐落在丛林外面。所以他们到了那里，把露西哄进其中一个笼子里，说了晚安，然后留下她一个人在户外度过第一个夜晚。
After a few weeks, Maurice and Jane Temerlin decided to leave. And the plan was that Janice, for just a little while, would stay behind. To help Lucy with the transition.
几周后，莫里斯和简·特默林决定离开。计划是珍妮丝留下来一段时间，帮助露西过渡。
She started to lose her hair and get skin infections. I wasn't happy being there either. I hated it.
她开始脱发并出现皮肤感染。我留在那儿也不开心。我讨厌那儿。
How long did you think you would be staying there?
你以为你会留多久？
Three weeks.
三周。
Three weeks. Wow. And so were saying that Janice Carter has actually never left.
三周。哇。所以你是说珍妮丝·卡特实际上再也没离开过。
At the end of those three weeks, there was just no way that I could leave Lucy.
三周结束时，我根本没法离开露西。
The weeks turn into months, and then into a year. And still, Lucy's stressed out. She's not eating, her hair is falling out. And by this point, a whole nother group of chimps shows up at this nature reserve. These were former captives like Lucy, and they start to deteriorate as well. So Janice decides what she needs to do is change locations. So she takes Lucy and all these other chimps to this abandoned island that she'd found.
几周变成了几个月，然后变成了一年。露西依然压力重重。她不吃东西，毛发在脱落。此时，另一群黑猩猩出现在这个自然保护区。这些也是像露西一样的曾经被囚禁的动物，它们也开始恶化。所以珍妮丝决定她需要换个地点。她带着露西和所有这些黑猩猩去了她发现的一个荒岛。
It's a long narrow island.
这是一个又长又窄的岛。
This is in the Gambia River.
在冈比亚河里。
It's a mile wide at its widest point. Very thick screen forest.
最宽处只有一英里。森林非常茂密。
And the idea here was that you would release them and they would be able to do whatever in the island and learn how to climb trees, and learn how to forage, and learn how to establish relationships with each other? Was that the notion?
这里的想法是释放它们，它们就能在岛上做任何事，学会爬树、学会觅食、学会建立彼此之间的关系？这就是最初的想法吗？
Yeah, in a nutshell. And you would think that if you gave them freedom, they would just jump for joy and that's the last chapter of the book.
是的，简而言之。你会以为如果你给它们自由，它们会跳得很高兴，那将是书的最后一章。
But it's not what happened. She says that when Lucy and the other chimps got to the island and she let them loose, they clung to her. During the day she'd walk them around the island and point out of them, here are the fruits you should be eating. These are the leaves you should be eating. They weren't interested in any of that stuff.
但这并没有发生。她说当露西和其他黑猩猩到达岛上时，她放它们出去，它们却紧紧缠着她。白天她带它们绕岛走，指点它们，这是你们应该吃的果子。这是你们应该吃的叶子。它们对这些东西一点兴趣都没有。
Oh no.
哦，不。
They were actually more interested in her stuff. Which was what they were used to.
它们实际上对她的东西更感兴趣。因为它们习惯了那些。
I had human objects and tools that I needed for my own survival and they wanted to use them. Like when I would cook or brush my teeth or take a bath, or anything that I wanted to do, they wanted to be doing it with me.
我有一些为了生存所需的人类物品和工具，它们想使用这些。就像我做饭、刷牙或洗澡，或者我想做的任何事，它们都想和我一起做。
Janice figured the only way this was going to work is if she could somehow keep the chimps away from her and her tools. And so here's where she does something really radical.
珍妮丝想，唯一可行的方法是如果她能以某种方式让黑猩猩远离她和她的工具。所以在这里她做了一件非常激进的事情。
She had run into a couple of British army officers who were passing through the Gambi on some kind of wilderness training thing. And she somehow convinced them to build her a cage, a giant metal industrial cage. Then to fly it over to her island.
她遇到了几个英国军官，他们正经过冈比亚进行某种野外训练。她不知怎么说服他们为她造了一个笼子，一个巨大的金属工业笼子。然后用飞机把它运到岛上。
In a helicopter.
用直升机。
And drop it thunk, right in the center. The thing about this cage is that it wasn't for the chimps. It was for her.
把它砰地一声扔在正中心。这个笼子的特别之处在于它不是为了关黑猩猩的。是为了关她自己的。
Yes.
是的。
You lived in a cage?
你住在笼子里？
I lived in a cage. Yes.
我住在笼子里。是的。
Wow.
哇。
And in the beginning she says, her cage didn't even have a roof.
而且她说，起初她的笼子甚至没有顶。
No. In the rainy season it rained on me.
不。在雨季，雨直接下在我身上。
The only thing above her head was this fine wire mesh to keep the chimps out.
她头顶上唯一的遮挡就是这层细铁丝网，为了把黑猩猩挡在外面。
The chimps all wanted to be inside with me. When I said, no, then they would climb on top of the cage and sleep out in the open on the wire on top right above me. Every time there was any sound in the night of a hyena or anything, they would immediately squeal and defecate and urinate right on top of me.
黑猩猩都想和我待在里面。我说不，它们就会爬上笼子顶，睡在头顶的铁丝网上。每当晚上有鬣狗或其他什么声音时，它们就会立刻尖叫，并在我头顶上方排泄。
Oh God.
噢，上帝。
Really?
真的吗？
Then I put [UNINTELLIGIBLE] on the roof. But then they started dancing on the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. They really liked the sound that it made. So they were all day long busy dancing. It sounds funny and it was at times. But it distracted them from being chimps.
然后我给屋顶加了[听不清]。但它们开始在那上面跳舞。它们真的很喜欢那种声音。所以它们整天忙着跳舞。这听起来很好笑，有时确实也很好笑。但这让它们分心，没法做一只真正的黑猩猩。
After about a year, says Janice, most of the chimps lost interest in her. Because they couldn't get her tools. She was stuck in a cage. They gave up. They stopped hanging around her and they'd just wonder off into the forest and forage for themselves.
大约一年后，珍妮丝说，大多数黑猩猩对她失去了兴趣。因为它们拿不到她的工具。她被关在笼子里。它们放弃了。它们停止围着她转，而是漫步到森林里，自己觅食。
Yet Lucy did stay behind. Due to the obvious reasons, I think she was different than all the rest of the chimps.
然而露西留下了。因为明显的原因，我觉得她和其他黑猩猩不同。
And so Janice and Lucy entered into a kind of sign language battle of wills.
于是珍妮丝和露西展开了一场手语意志力的较量。
If I came out of the tent to look to see if they were all gone, there she was right there looking really forlorn at me and using sign language to tell me to come out to be with her.
如果我走出帐篷看它们是不是都走了，她就站在那儿，表情忧伤地看着我，并用手语告诉我出来陪她。
But Janice would sign to Lucy, no Lucy, go.
但珍妮丝会打手语对露西说，不，露西，走。
Go.
走。
Lucy would then sign back, no, Janice come.
露西会回打手语说，不，珍妮丝，过来。
No, Lucy go.
不，露西，走。
No Janice come.
不，珍妮丝，过来。
Lucy go.
露西，走。
And this went on and on.
这持续了很久。
I tried and I tried and I tried and I tried.
我试了又试，试了又试。
But Lucy wouldn't move. She would just stand there, waiting for Janice to help her.
但露西就是不动。她只是站在那里，等着珍妮丝帮助她。
Sometimes I would stay inside the tent all day long and I would try to ignore her, ignore that she was there. Thinking that if I ignored her, then she'd go off with the others. But that didn't work. And if I did look at her, then she would sign that she was hurt. She would use the sign for hurt.
有时我会整天待在帐篷里，试图忽略她，忽略她的存在。以为如果我忽略她，她就会和其他伙伴一起离开。但这没用。如果我看着她，她就会用手语说她受伤了。她会用“痛”的手语。
Meanwhile, she wasn't foraging for herself. She was getting thinner.
与此同时，她没有自己觅食。她越来越瘦。
And I tried everything and really, really knocked myself out trying to do things for her. And I just started to think maybe she never was going to do it. And we would argue about it. I ate everything. I was eating ants, I was eating the sticky [? latex ?] and figs. I was doing everyhing that I was trying really nauseating to do just so that she will watch me do it and think, wow, if she's doing it, then I'm going to do it too. And she wouldn't do it. She'd just turn her head away. And I honestly thought at one point that she would rather starve to death than have to work for her food. I was losing hope.
我试了一切，真的耗尽了精力试图为她做点什么。我开始想，也许她永远也不会去做了。我们为此争论。我什么都吃。我吃蚂蚁，我吃那种黏糊糊的[听不清]和无花果。我努力做一切令人作呕的事，只为了让她看着我吃，心想，哇，如果她在吃，那我也要吃。但她就是不吃。她只是转过头去。我真的有一度认为，她宁愿饿死也不愿为了食物而劳动。我当时快绝望了。
But incredibly, Janice kept at this for years. She'd have to toss Lucy some food, some of her's, just to keep Lucy from starving. But she kept at it.
但令人难以置信的是，珍妮丝坚持了这么多年。她有时会扔给露西一些食物，她自己的一些食物，只是为了让露西不被饿死。但她坚持下来了。
And then, one evening, after a really, really long day--
然后，在一个傍晚，经过非常非常漫长的一天——
Oh, what a drag of a day.
哦，真是糟糕的一天。
Janice and Lucy are walking through the forest and they both stop because they're so beat. And crash.
珍妮丝和露西走在森林里，她们都因为太累而停了下来。晕倒了。
And we just, we fell asleep.
我们只是，睡着了。
On the ground together.
一起躺在地上。
And when I woke up, Lucy was actually holding my hand. And she had a leaf.
当我醒来时，露西实际上握着我的手。她拿着一片叶子。
She's holding out a leaf?
她递出一片叶子？
Yes. She reached out and she offered it to me. And then I offered it to her. And she ate it. It was a miracle. It was an absolute miracle.
是的。她伸出手递给我。然后我也递给她。她吃了。这是一个奇迹。绝对的奇迹。
And after that says Janice--
珍妮丝说，在那之后——
She was turned.
她彻底变了。
And actually, from that moment on Lucy did start to make the effort and go off?
实际上，从那一刻起，露西确实开始努力去独自生活了？
And be a chimp?
去做一只黑猩猩？
That's Charles Siebert again.
那是查尔斯·西伯特。
And it was not too long after that that Janice went away and--
在那之后没多久，珍妮丝就离开了，并且——
Left the island?
离开了那个岛？
Yeah.
是的。
Janice says she'd periodically circle in a boat just to keep an eye on Lucy. But she says she never, not once, set foot on that island. At least not for a year. Then one day she decided to go back.
珍妮丝说她会定期划船转圈，只是为了照看露西。但她说，她一次也没有，哪怕是一次，踏上那个岛。至少一年内没有。然后有一天她决定回去。
This day is the first day that I went actually on the island.
这是我实际登上岛的第一天。
She pulled her boat up to the tip of the island where there's just a little clearing and she parked. And as she did, Lucy and the other chimps who had heard the boat, came out of the forest and into the clearing. And Lucy and her walked toward each other.
她把船划到岛的顶端，那里有一片小空地，她停了下来。当她停下时，听见船声的露西和其他黑猩猩从森林里出来，来到空地上。露西和她朝对方走去。
And I took with me some of Lucy's possession that had been important to her, like her mirror. And she used to like to draw and books, just to see how she responded to it.
我带了一些露西以前拥有的、对她很重要的东西，比如她的镜子。她以前喜欢画画，还有书，只是想看看她会有什么反应。
And what did she do?
她做了什么？
Well she looked at the things. She looked at the book. She looked at herself in the mirror and she signed to herself in the mirror. Then all of a sudden she grabbed me. I mean really grabbed me. One arm circled all the way around me and she sort of held me really, really tight. It really made me breathless and I started crying. She started begin these soft little pants. And I'm still pretty certain what she was saying to me was it's OK. You know, it's all OK now.
嗯，她看着那些东西。她看书。她照镜子看着自己，然后对着镜子里的自己打手语。然后突然她抓住了我。我是说真的抓住了我。一只手臂完全环绕着我，她紧紧地抱着我。这让我喘不过气来，我开始哭泣。她开始发出那种柔和的喘息声。我相信她当时对我说的肯定是“没关系”。你知道，现在一切都好起来了。
At that moment, somebody in Janice's boat snapped a picture of her and Lucy hugging. It's a picture that Charles Siebert printed in his book. And it's one of those images that when you see it, I don't know why, it just haunts you.
就在那一刻，珍妮丝船上的某个人拍下了她和露西拥抱的照片。那是查尔斯·西伯特在他书中印出的照片。那是一张当你看到时，我不知道为什么，它就是会萦绕在你心头的照片。
Lucy has their head against Janice's chest and Janice has her arms around Lucy.
露西把头靠在珍妮丝的胸前，珍妮丝双臂环抱着露西。
It's one of the more fraught moments. You have to just look at the picture. I mean it sort of made me want to write the book. Something about the complexity and the invertedness of that picture.
这是最令人揪心的时刻之一。你必须看看那张照片。它让我有了写这本书的冲动。照片中那种复杂和颠倒的关系。
After that, the other chimps had started to go. And she wanted to go with them. And she got up and she didn't turn back to look at me. She just kept walking. She wanted to go with the other chimps and she did.
在那之后，其他黑猩猩开始出发了。她想和它们一起走。她站起来，没有回头看我。她只是继续走。她想去追随其他黑猩猩，她做到了。
A year later, Janice went back to visit Lucy again. But when she got there, this time Lucy was gone.
一年后，珍妮丝又去探望露西。但当她到那里时，这次露西不见了。
And I went to all the different places looking to see if we could find anything. And we did. We found her body.
我去了所有不同的地方寻找，看看能不能找到什么线索。我们确实找到了。我们找到了她的遗骸。
She was lying right near the place where Janice's cage had been, just a skeleton.
她躺在珍妮丝曾经住过笼子的地方附近，只剩下一具骨架。
Her skull and her hands and her feet were separated from the rest of her skeleton.
她的头骨、手和脚与骨架的其他部分分开了。
So how did you know that that was her body?
那么你怎么知道那就是她的遗体？
She had a split between her front teeth and she was very long. And there was nobody else missing.
她的前牙之间有缝隙，而且她长得很长。没有其他人失踪了。
And maybe the saddest, strangest thing was that--
也许最令人伤心、最奇怪的是——
We didn't find any signs of her skin or hair.
我们没有发现任何皮肤或毛发的迹象。
It appeared that Lucy had been skinned.
看起来露西被剥皮了。
And no one knows actually what happened. But because the hands were taken, which poachers do, they thought one of the conjectures which makes it really unbelievably tragic is that they think that Lucy, always the first to approach humans, just sort of guilelessly approached poachers, not knowing that they were that. And that they just took advantage of their unwitting and over eager prey. But that was Lucy's end.
没有人知道到底发生了什么。但因为她的手被拿走了，这是偷猎者会做的，他们推测，其中一个推测让这件事变得令人难以置信地悲惨，他们认为露西，总是第一个接近人类，只是单纯地接近了偷猎者，不知道他们是谁。他们只是利用了她这种毫无防备且过于热情的猎物。这就是露西的结局。
The scenario that I have developed to cope with her death is that a fisherman or someone, some local person that just happened to pull up next to the land and was going to take a break or [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] or do something. And because she always felt confidence around humans, she probably approached the person. Perhaps she surprised the person and just on reflexes, defense, she was probably shot. I've got no other explanation.
我为应对她的死亡而构建的一个假设是，一个渔民或某个人，某个当地人，正好把船停在岸边打算休息一下，或者做些什么。因为她总是对人类感到自信，她可能接近了那个人。也许她吓到了那个人，出于反射防御，她可能被射杀了。我没有其他解释。
Janice Carter still lives in Gambia. It's then when she realized that the chimps there would never have a chance to survive unless their human neighbors understood that might be a good thing. So these days she spends a lot of her time teaching people in Gambia about chimps, to convince them about the importance of protecting the chimps habitat.
珍妮丝·卡特依然住在冈比亚。那是她意识到，除非当地人类邻居明白保护黑猩猩是件好事，否则那里的黑猩猩永远没有生存的机会。所以这些日子，她花了很多时间在冈比亚教育人们关于黑猩猩的知识，让他们相信保护黑猩猩栖息地的重要性。
Charles Siebert's latest book, all about the midway point between animals and humans is The Wauchula Woods Accord.
查尔斯·西伯特关于人类与动物之间中间地带的最新著作是《瓦丘拉森林协定》。
Radiolab is a production of New York's Public radio station WNYC, distributed around the country by NPR. If you go to the Radiolab website this week, you can see that eerie photo that they talked about with Janice Carter and Lucy embracing. Radiolab.org.
《放射实验室》是纽约公共广播电台WNYC的制作，由NPR在全国发行。如果你这周访问《放射实验室》的网站，你可以看到那张他们谈到的珍妮丝·卡特和露西相拥的诡异照片。Radiolab.org。
I just want to put a personal plug in here. If you're already not downloading the free podcast of Radiolab that comes out every two weeks, you are missing the most adventurous, enjoyable news show in public radio. Thanks to the Radiolab hosts Jad Abumrad and Robert Krulwich. And to Lulu Miller who did some of the production work on this story.
我只是想在这里做一个个人推荐。如果你还没有下载每两周发布一次的免费《放射实验室》播客，你就错过了公共广播中最具冒险性和愉悦感的新闻节目。感谢《放射实验室》主持人贾德·阿布姆拉德和罗伯特·克鲁维奇。还要感谢在这集故事制作中贡献工作的露露·米勒。
[MUSIC- "I CAN'T MAKE IT ALONE" BY LOU RAWLS]
[音乐- 卢·罗尔斯的《我无法独自承受》]
Well our program was produced today by Robyn Semien and myself with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Lisa Pollak, Sarah Koenig, Alissa Shipp and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer's Julie Snyder with production help from Brian Reed. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon's our office manager. Our music consultant is Jessica Hopper.
我们的节目今天由罗宾·塞米恩和我制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格、简·费尔特斯、丽莎·波拉克、萨拉·凯尼格、艾丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德，布莱恩·里德提供制作帮助。塞思·林德是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康顿是我们的办公室经理。我们的音乐顾问是杰西卡·霍珀。
A program note. That interview that I did with Dave Hill at the top of today's show about his mom was recorded about three weeks ago. Last week, his mom, Bernadette Hill, though everybody called her Bunny, died at the age of 80. Dave has been on our show and around our office a lot lately. He wrote the song about the Erie Canal in last week's show. And our thoughts are with him and with his family.
节目公告。今天节目开始时我采访戴夫·希尔关于他母亲的内容是大约三周前录制的。上周，他的母亲伯纳黛特·希尔，尽管大家叫她邦妮，在80岁时去世了。戴夫最近经常上我们的节目并出现在我们的办公室。他在上周的节目里写了关于伊利运河的歌。我们向他和他的家人表示慰问。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Tory Malatia, who hears himself here in the credits each week next to the funders and the thank you's and all our names. And he just doesn't understand why.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。我们节目的WBEZ管理监督是我们老板托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他每周在节目结尾的致谢名单中都能听到自己的名字，紧挨着资助者和感谢名单以及我们的名字。他就是不明白为什么。
I don't know. Normally, I understand why I'm somewhere. I know why. But I guess I don't know, I don't know why I'm here.
我不知道。通常我知道自己为什么会在某个地方。我知道原因。但我猜我不知道，我不知道我为什么会在这儿。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of this American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。